so the kids who attend chicago public
schools don't have it easy they live in
one of the most violent and crime-ridden
places in the country as of november 1st
678 people had been murdered in the city
outpacing the murder rate from 2020
which was itself historically high
homelessness is also on the rise along
with drug abuse and nearly every marker
of
societal disintegration the poverty rate
in chicago is 20 percent
these dire conditions can be felt in the
school system itself where the violence
from the street often spills into the
hallways and the classrooms as you might
expect the schools are so infected and
surrounded by violence that many
students are scared to walk home at the
end of the day earlier this year two 15
year old students at one chicago school
were shot and killed in separate
shootings on the same day near the
school they attended
this is what it's like to attend class
inside a war zone basically
academically chicago schools are subpar
at best their elementary age students
are below the national average in both
math and reading the situation is so bad
that the school system brags about a
graduation rate of only 82 percent
also considerably below the national
average granted it's an improvement from
the catastrophic 60 graduation rate of
2007
but still not very good all in all
suffice it to say that chicago public
schools have problems
major problems
and they aren't focused on solving any
of them instead the district has set
inclusivity as one of its primary goals
and it most especially wants to impose
inclusivity in the bathrooms
now as a normal insane person you have
probably been inside hundreds of public
restrooms and never once thought to
yourself that the environment needed to
be more inclusive
it's likely that you've you you have
never looked around and said yeah i
really wish there was a more diverse
array of people
uh peeing alongside me
you may take note of many other
improvements that could be made inside
any particular public restroom most of
them hygiene and sanitation related but
diversity and inclusivity were probably
not among them
but the chicago public school system
like so many other school systems is not
run by people like you
it's run by weirdos and predators and
perverts who have never met a
heteronormative quote unquote
arrangement that they don't want to
dismantle
and that's why the district announced
this week that all bathrooms in all of
its schools at every grade level will be
made gender-neutral from henceforward
they proudly released a video where kami
pratt and deb spraggins
their top title ix officers and chief
groomers
announced the change let's watch this
hello everyone i'm cammy pratt the
district's chief title 9 officer and i'm
debs fraggins the district's deputy
chief title 9 officer the new school
year is off to a strong start as we've
welcomed our students back to our school
buildings five days each week on top of
ensuring that each of our schools is a
safe learning environment we're also
taking steps to create more inclusive
and supportive schools
one change that will be implemented this
school year relates to our school
bathrooms in compliance with new federal
guidelines all cps students and staff
will have fair and equitable access to
bathroom facilities that align with
their gender identity we will be
providing all schools with updated
signage that makes our bathrooms more
inclusive it will identify the fixtures
available in each restroom and make it
clear that all restrooms are open for
use by anyone who feels comfortable
staff will continue to have staff only
restrooms available to them this is an
incredibly important step to increase
gender equity for all which is why we
will be requiring all schools to post
this signage by december 1st of this
school year our district's office of
student protections and title ix is also
working on a long-term plan to create
more permanent signage for our bathrooms
i encourage you to visit our website at
cps.edu
forward slash osp to learn more about
our comprehensive approach to creating
more inclusive equitable and safe
schools
if you have any questions you can email
us at osp
cps.edu we look forward to having a safe
and successful school year at every
school in every neighborhood across
chicago thank you
and to make the dystopian feel uh you
know the the dystopian theme to make it
complete of course we have in the video
footage of kids walking around with
masks on their face the signage on the
bathrooms will read boys plus and girls
plus with a note indicating that quote
all who feel comfortable are welcome to
use this restroom
this of course does not take into
account the fact that for most
well-adjusted people their comfort level
in the bathroom depends on who else is
allowed to use it
most girls feel comfortable using the
girls restroom because there will only
be girls inside it
these girls will not feel comfortable if
anyone else if anyone else who feels
comfortable regardless of sex is allowed
to join them
the upshot is that normal girls with a
normal desire for privacy and safety
will not feel comfortable anywhere now
in chicago public schools there is no
restroom for them to use
for the sake of providing comfort to the
tiny minority of gender non-conformists
the comfort of everybody else must be
sacrificed
for normal girls that is a cis girls as
they're now called in an effort to
marginalize normalcy the signs ought to
simply say go to hell we don't care
about you
because after all that is the message
well if you're looking for the perfect
gift for the holiday for yourself or
someone else get these kamikoto knives
these knives are perfect they're
beautiful they feel great you probably
should not hold three in your hand at
one time but i will i'm don't do this at
home kids i'm an expert uh ken makoto
taps into more than 800 years of
traditional techniques from hanshu japan
each kamikoto knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete because of their single bevel
edge kamikota knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you can't get
with other knives they can cut through
your rib eye like butter um and they're
they they're also lightweight they work
perfectly chemical knives are used by
several chefs working at michelin star
restaurants and when you get these
knives you can really tell why so go
click the link below or go to
kamikoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh
to save an extra 50
today
this is not about comfort generally
speaking and it's not about being
inclusive or tolerant
if the policy was motivated by those
desires i'd still oppose it
because inclusivity tolerance and
comfort cannot be the overriding
concerns in a bathroom or really
anywhere else in life
but as it happens
those are not the concerns here at all
as always the predators and groomers are
using these nice sounding words as
window dressing for their true agenda in
this case the real point is to institute
a social hierarchy where the desires of
the uber victims those in the lgbt camp
especially trans people are placed
explicitly above
the needs of those who are their
inferiors
normal girls and boys
are punished for being normal
these are basically punitive measures
these punitive measures have by design a
sort of if you can't beat em join em
effect after a while kids are so
immersed in gender ideology so subject
to its commands even in bathrooms that
eventually they're worn down and they
learn to accept it and then after a
while embrace it
you've probably already taken note of
the timing of this bathroom policy
change in chicago it comes directly on
the heels of a of a of a major national
scandal in loudoun county that we
uncovered here at the daily wire where a
girl was brutally raped inside a girl's
bathroom by a boy in a dress now some on
social media have said that they they
can't believe that chicago would instate
this policy
in spite of what happened in virginia
but they're wrong
chicago is not doing this now in spite
of the loudoun county scandal they're
doing it now because of that scandal
the groomers and predators and
brainwashers of children are not backing
away in shame
because that happened
they certainly won't change course out
of any concern for the safety of
children they don't care if kids are
raped in the bathroom they don't care
they only care if the raping becomes
inconvenient to the trans agenda
the well-being of children is not a
priority at all
it does not factor into the equation
they don't think about it
and that is not an exaggeration
i guarantee you in chicago when they
were coming up with this policy and
talking about it
no one even said
well are we worried about girls
their well-being i mean
are we worried about their safety
what if they what if they end up getting
abused or raped in the bath
that's not not an issue they don't care
what matters is that every aspect of
student life conforms with the demands
of leftist ideology and especially
gender ideology and any amount of
suffering is a worthy trade
towards that end
that's why chicago is doing this now
they're doubling down
they're sending a message to the
domestic terrorists i.e parents who
value their children's safety and
well-being and the message is your kids
are ours
we own them
we will do what we want with them and to
them
i said before that chicago isn't focused
on addressing the violence and chaos in
its schools
and uh that's true but i i should
mention that they did announce this year
a new plan what they call a healing
centered framework
to help kids cope with trauma related to
violence covet and other struggles
it's not clear what this will entail
exactly but we do know that it will cost
25 million dollars whatever they do with
it
i wonder if the girls who will now be
abused raped harassed and accosted in
the school's bathrooms will have access
to those healing-centered services
something tells me they will not
because their trauma doesn't count
just like their feelings and their
comfort and their privacy doesn't count
[Music]
it all must be sacrificed on the lgbt
alter well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content